I recreated the everything bagel from
everything everywhere all at once
typically Bagel making is a super labor
intensive process but this two
ingredient Bagel hack is pretty insane
you just combine yogurt and flour and
need it into the perfect consistency and
shape quite contrary to the bagel with
literally everything in the universe on
it as portrayed in the movie the result
is so perfect it makes me feel like I
first jumped with a pro Baker version of
myself in a parallel universe these are
the perfect snack to share for an
Oscar's viewing party where we celebrate
the absolute Excellence of this film
from the dazzling costumes to the
mind-blowing editing to making rakakuni
the sidekick I never knew I needed the
incredible performances of Michelle yo
Kihei Quan and Stephanie Shu made me
feel so many things I didn't expect and
one of those things was hope hope that
in the absolutely dismal moments of life
when you feel more like nothing nowhere
never matters love finds a way to
disrupt our pessimism and make things
make a little more sense so that's why